tonight's broadcast on espn at seven
eastern time including jay bilas who's
back here on the show how are you jay
great richard how are you i am doing
just fine i am doing just fine
um so seven eastern time tonight you're
you're in bristol right
you're who's with you walk me through
the broadcast this evening we've got
rhys davis
is uh is the lead on this thing and uh
we've got mike schmitz
uh who's one of the the best talent
evaluators i've ever been around bobby
marks who spent uh
a career in nba front offices uh jay
williams
uh adrian wojnarowski uh we got a we got
a a pretty good crew
fantastic and is there an nba draft
bubble or are we gonna see commissioner
silver like commissioner goodell uh
announcing draft choices from his uh
basement
or uh man cave what are we seeing no
adam silver and mark tatum will both be
uh on the espn campus
so he'll he'll have a little green room
uh and walk out with each pick get
behind a podium
and so from that standpoint it'll look
similar that the players won't be there
and it won't be in you know sort of a
cavernous arena like madison square
garden or the barclays center in
brooklyn
so that'll be a little different and we
won't have people yelling at us
when we make a mistake stuff like that
from the crowd you're sure about that
jay i mean you might you might have a
plumber you might have some executives
come down and yell at you you know you
never know
i mean uh yeah yeah jimmy pateron may
come down and uh you know
give a quick pinky pink slip you know
like the give me the hook
yeah that wouldn't be that wouldn't be a
surprise you won't just remember it's
it's called disney plus jay that's
called disney plus
make sure that you you work that in and
i think everything will be fine
i may be delivering those pizzas that
are coming your way
you're just gonna be just fine so that's
cool so the commissioner will be there
that's cool and then um and then the
players i assume will all be in
in their spots who who's the first one
tonight give me your your two cents of
what's going to happen tonight
yeah i think it'll be anthony edwards of
georgia uh i think he's the best
prospect you know my colleague mike
schmitz who's
as good a talent evaluators i've ever
known uh has lamelo ball is the overall
uh best prospect and the the best talent
uh i happen to think it's edwards but
reasonable minds can differ on that
um i i tip toward edwards just because
he's a he's a spectacular athlete in
addition to being a big time scorer
and uh just a freight train uh in
transition
and uh can get to the rim i thought he
settled for jump shots too much he
should have thought uh shot a lot more
free throws
and he's not all the time focused
defensively but when he does sit down in
a stance he is hard to deal with
uh but i think he's got the the the best
chance to be a to be an all-star
player and then uh i'm a big believer in
james weisman out of memphis he only
played three games last year because
that whole ncaa issue he got involved in
but
uh if this draft for five or ten years
ago james wiseman would have been a no
the no brainer number one pick it would
have been
close uh he's a 7-1 uh kind of chris
bosh type player with a
7-6 wingspan so he can run he's mobile
laterally
i think he can shoot it so i think he's
going to be able to step away and knock
down
knock down an nba three so i think he's
a really good fit for the warriors if
they decide to keep the pick and not
trade out of it
and so uh that would leave lamello for
michael jordan do you think that yeah i
called that at the top of the show the
uh mothership mother lode
that's uh that would be it you know i
mean that that michael jordan
who was once uh challenged to a
one-on-one contest by levar because
levar said he could win it
um drafting lamello would that would be
oh i didn't even think about that
that would be interesting yeah i mean if
you get a chance to ask lavar questions
straight out of that pick so i don't
have to deal with that
if lamelo gets drafted tonight and you
do get a a question in to levar you got
to ask him if he's going to challenge uh
the guy who's going to be writing
lamella's checks to a one-on-one contest
to see if he could back it up
but that i mean yeah i don't think i'm
going to be i don't think i'm going to
be interviewing him
i will be completely frank with you i i
basically said i would never mention his
name again
after he went after that female official
on a you ball
i thought this misogynistic clown uh is
not worth my time
and i haven't really changed my mind um
you know his son is a great player
and uh and lonzo ball is a great player
um i actually think that that lamelo
is a better playmaker than lonzo he
doesn't shoot it quite as well as lonzo
and he's nowhere near the defender lonzo
is uh but uh but you know uh levar ball
and his wife raised some some terrific
kids and uh and terrific players but i
have no i have no patience for him
absolutely so then lamelo
would fit how um you know you're
you're talking about him or that he's
being bandied about potentially he's the
best prospect here
um six seven in you know uh soaking wet
a
buck eighty right now uh potentially not
bigger than that over the
over the whole workout period you know
they've had a lot longer to work out
than
cova than any any prospects in history
that have declared for the draft
but um so he's bigger and stronger than
he was when all those measurements are
taken but
he's he's great in transition and he's
fantastic with the ball um
he's just a wizard uh uh with that with
his handle
and his passing and and can deliver
really
almost any pass i think the downside
with him
is he does he is not a defender can he
be one he's not a he's not an
overwhelming athlete like uh
like anthony edwards is so it's but but
he can guard somebody if he wants to he
just hasn't wanted to yet
and then and then he doesn't shoot it uh
can he become a better shooter yes
is he gonna be a really good shooter i i
doubt it
but but you never know some some players
when they get into the nba they really
you know have a have a big uptick in
shooting others don't
um but i think with with work he can
become a competent shooter
in the nba but he hasn't been to this
point and and rich it's been a long time
since he's finished a season
uh you know he played in australia
didn't finish the season didn't really
finish uh
season in lithuania when he played pro
ball as a high school kid and then he
didn't finish his high school season so
um you know that that's a that's an
issue but not
uh it's not disqualifying or anything
jay bill is here on the rich eisen show
and again i know your belly wick is
talent evaluation and seeing where fits
are
and and things of that nature and not
the trading uh
aspect of it that's kind of woj's uh
bailly wick
uh that said everything is baileywick i
mean i call him for the weather and to
find out what stocks to buy he knows
everything first
[Laughter]
there's a lot of loach bombs no doubt
about it uh but
if the warriors did trade down to four
because the bulls
coveted wiseman so much and they just
couldn't
uh they couldn't uh refuse that offer
who do you think they'd be targeting it
for
who do you think is is is that player
jay there are a couple that i think they
would really really like there one is
denny abdia
who's a a six nine uh skilled
big guy from israel
so he played for maccabee tel aviv and
really really talented player that is
still very young but has uh
has a lot of experience internationally
obviously
and then there are a couple others that
i think would be interesting for them
one is isaac okoro
out of auburn i don't know if they'd
want to take him number four
because i think he'd be available even
further down maybe seven
um but uh he's the only thing okoro
doesn't do yet
is is shoot it really well from the
perimeter
but man he he literally defends one
through five
and uh a real real competitor i mean
he's legit
i'm i'm a big big believer in him and
the other
i would say would be tyrese halliburton
um and there's some that say well
halliburton should go you know sort of
in the seven
eight range uh i i rank him as the
fourth best prospect in the draft i mean
this is a draft that doesn't have a lot
of
you know sort of no brainer great
prospects um it's not like
oh three that had you know lebron and
carmelo and and
bosh and uh dwyane wade all that stuff
but it's got a bunch of
good players that are going to be in the
league a long time and halliburton's
ready to plug in right now
as a as a big point guard with long arms
that can defend
and pass and shoot and handle
um there there's and he's uh he's can't
miss as far as being a
a long time you know 10 12 year starter
in the league as long as he stays
healthy
who's that mid first round guy who's
that donovan mitchell who do you got for
me
who do you got for me there could be
donovan mitchell he's a superstar
i like devin vasel a lot i don't know
that he'll go in the middle of the draft
there are two guys
i'd say devin vasala florida state who i
think is the best
perimeter defender in the draft wing
defender
uh right there with okoro um and and
he's very talented and you know he can
score
uh rebounds his position and and really
guards and and put up really good
numbers even though he didn't play full
games because of the way leonard
hamilton at florida state likes to
substitute and keep pressure on opposing
teams
and the other would be sadiq bay uh he's
not donovan mitchell
with his explosiveness but he heck of
not
and but available you really dig in on
them you're going okay there's got to be
something wrong with this guy
you know he doesn't make his bed in the
morning or or he leaves his towels on
the floor in hotels there's got to be
something he does wrong and i haven't
found it yet
jay bella's here on the rich eisen show
tonight 7 eastern time rhys davis and
woj in the cast of thousands
including adam silver up there in
bristol uh along with the rest of the
crew
for the nba draft okay jay i reached out
to you last week because
we have this caper we have uh some
shenanigans here but
we still treat this very seriously the
mixture between pogba trunks
very serious thing i considered what we
just talked about to be the shenanigans
okay this is something i've been
preparing for my whole life okay
i figured you'd be the guy to reach out
to we have four fictional characters
uh from uh from film lore uh basketball
characters
that we're wondering who would make the
best nba draft prospect i'm gonna go one
by one with you and then at the end i'll
ask you to rank them all if that's fine
with you jay
you ready of course okay first up is the
point guard from the venice beach locals
uh sydney dean uh what's your what's
your take on him in his uh draftability
well sidney dean from white men can't
jump great handle
somewhat of a trash talker a little bit
of a gym rat and
but really hustles uh out on the floor
that's right uh
the blacktop really he never he's not
yet played an indoor game
it's all been outdoors so uh you know
his jump shot may be
pushed by the wind to go in or or to go
out we'll see
you know how he does in an indoor game
he is undersized and tends to over
dribble a little bit
and uh and he also tends to hustle in a
in a negative fashion
but he has played against quality
competition including freeman williams
uh nigel miguel who played at ucla
marcus johnson was in that movie
and then gary moller who played at uc
santa barbara whose dad pitched for the
dodgers joe moeller
so put it all together and that's his
that's his uh
we we came with a comp of gary payton
but way shorter that's uh would you
agree with that uh comp
jay yeah gary wouldn't agree with it
because he was actually in that movie
although didn't receive
any credit uh in the uh in the credits
so i i think he's still pretty pissed
off about that okay so that's sydney
dean next up
um next up is from
hickory high school uh shooting guard
jimmy chitwood
jay what do you think about his
draftability
jimmy chitwood spot-up shooter tends to
demand the ball
especially in huddles uh he'll make his
teammates better although not
particularly supportive of ali when he
uh took that
free throw those free throws at the end
of the game the underhands against
the underhanded free throws against
cedar knob was the opponent
and who doesn't enjoy saying cedar knob
on national radio
uh the problem he's he's not always
motivated
and uh jimmy chitwood tends to get a
little chummy with the alumni
and i think a little questionable
relationship with his teacher barbara
hershey
whoa thompson with uh without the
defense
and people don't know this about jimmy
chitwood he was all state in golf
and actually went to purdue and was uh
was found for that movie in an open gym
because he was cut three times from his
high school basketball team no
kidding wow that's some interesting
information and he just
again the question can he create his own
shot here of course that's
interesting information that's right
that's it's jay bilas the question is
can he create his own shot though you
know what i'm saying like does he need
it to be drawn up on the board can he
just improvise that's the question about
jimmy chitwood
well he doesn't he does he never gets
caught watching the paint drive that's
true
that's true that's a that is definitely
uh a plus
uh next up another high schooler from
carver high
center warren coolidge what do you think
of his draft ability jay
physically imposing rebounds at a high
level was coached by
uh an nba player ken reeves who had a
wonderful fictional career with the
chicago bulls before getting injured
yeah i was talking about a fantastic
locker room singing voice
uh and uh reminds you a lot of ben
wallace with uh with sort of a barry
white voice but the problem is you know
tends to be a little
unmotivated and wasn't necessarily the
best player
on that show wolf perry was on that show
who played at stanford and then you may
not know this but uh jay bilas was once
on that show
do tell jay do tell really you knew that
i told you that i was in high school and
one of my high school teammates his
father dick baker
was the technical consultant for the
show and uh and so he got us on the show
and i
i wound up uh the show opened yes the
show we were on opened with me getting
yelled at
by our coach i was the supposed to be
the quote-unquote best player at oak
ridge high school which one of the
carver guys rhys had transferred to
and uh and the show opened with me
getting yelled at in the locker room
which you know was foreshadowing for my
college career plan for coach
oh my gosh i didn't know that so did
carver
beat you in on the white shadow did did
you lose to carver in that episode of
course not
no no one would buy that nonsense once
they saw me on the floor
they had to sell that to the public
that's they did all right last one for
you
uh this is uh he plays tons of position
guard forward and center from beacon
hills high school
uh teen wolf jay what do you think about
his uh abilities
whose name uh in the film was scott
howard when he wasn't
wasn't a wolf great vertical lead plays
above the rim
i think you could refer to him literally
and figuratively as a beast
uh only 5'3 but plays much bigger
the problem is he comes from a small
town in nebraska
so he'd have to cut family ties and then
he's uh
occasionally violent although his hair
is perfect
well by the way i love it peek larry
johnson with
bill walton's 1977 beard that that that
uh
that's a good comp don't you think did
you get the did you get the family ties
i picked it up i did pick that up
very very good i did all right so so
rank
all right this indeed uh so rank them
for me uh one through uh i'll go four
through uh i guess to one which one do
you
think is uh is least uh uh nba prospect
worthy and then
the best jay i would probably say number
four
would be uh jimmy chitwood
because of his lack of defense okay uh
then i'd go with teen wolf number three
um sydney dean uh i would have number
two
and then you gotta go with warren
coolidge uh because if there was
actually
actually a game by the actor that played
the parts yes uh warren coolidge would
be
would win in a landslide he was he was
the best player of that crew
okay very good jay i appreciate it that
was uh stellar
as expected as expected that was just
absolutely stellar
and did you did you have somebody that
we forgot is there somebody out there
that you think
should have been could uh thrown in here
in this mix
i think julia's irving no nothing no no
i mean a non-nba player a non-nba player
jackie moon okay maybe we'll have to
figure that one out for later jackie
moon's not a bad one
well i guess he's semi-pro was he
semi-pro or different he's professional
in a way but
jackie moon isn't cool the florida
tropics that's a real team i mean if
you're taking a guy
off the playground in venice beach you
can go with you can go with the florida
tropics
or the uh flint drop excuse me the point
drop the flint tropics that's right
oh my gosh jay have a great time tonight
i'll be there with my kids we'll be
watching
we'll uh always a pleasure richie right
and uh
by the way you know you're talking about
espn and your time there
you don't know this but all of us all of
us went down
and put our ties down on george
bodenheimer's desk
to get you your shot i didn't even know
that
by the way i didn't even know i did that
we are not going on the air
until richie eisen gets his shot he's
earned it
my problem with these guys doing that
early and they did
they knew they know i despised notre
dame and rudy with the passion they know
it
they're all trying to get my ghost i
didn't know that stop it no
stop it stop it but i appreciate that i
didn't know that jay i
then uh thank you years later you owe me
a tie because i haven't gotten it back
i look forward to seeing your tie
tonight thanks for the call jay you're
the best man
thanks thank you you're the best that's
jay billis
warren coolidge wins it that was awesome
ben wallace with the barry white singing
voice everybody
that's his comp ivy we knew he'd nailed
that
he'd stick the landings perfect and well
done to sean mitchell creating all those
draft profiles
family ties line